I'm dr. conscience I'm the CEO in
communications I know many of you if you
have any questions please don't hesitate
to throw them in wherever they are the
talk today is going to go at two levels
it's going to go at one level relatively
high to motivate why you're doing what
you're try to do it the other level is
going down into the weeds as to what it
is in the physics and the engineering of
what you're building as to what the
essential trade-offs are that you're
working against so the outline of what
we're going to go through today is first
let's talk about the future of wireless
communications where we're going what
some of the challenges are what some of
the dead ends are that we've run into
software radios promise some realized
mostly unrealized making a software
radio actually work the way that it was
originally envisioned some in here can
tell me when that started where we are
now some of the imminent changes that
are on the immediate horizon
some of them validated earlier today and
what that means for the paths forward
and how we will see the wireless
environment that we work in changed
dramatically over the next five to ten
years whoops excuse me in the future we
live in a resource-constrained
environment and when you think about
wireless you want to understand that
there are three fundamental constraints
you need to worry about we have
constraints in spectrum we have
constraints in bandwidth and we have
constraints in power and you need to
work within those and if we're going to
expand what we're doing for data for
everybody everything coming over those
pieces of operation we need to do a hell
of a lot better than we're doing today
and within that there are three key ways
that we're going to do that I'm going to
talk about them very loosely something
called dynamic spectrum access which
many of you may be aware of something
called MIMO or massive MIMO which I
assume
most of you are aware of and something
which we'll call a universal handset
which has been kind of a Holy Grail in
this industry for about three or four
decades I'm gonna just show this and
then I'm gonna go on and if you want me
to come back to it in detail I'm happy
to do it we are humble engineers despite
the name miracle we didn't name it one
of our customers when we were describing
what it was she kept asking questions of
well so you can't do this
no we can do that you can't do that well
of course we can do that why else would
you want to have it she finally dropped
down and said this is a miracle and the
name stuck and we're a little bit
embarrassed about that but that's where
it is we'll come back to this in detail
the fundamental thing I want to point
out to you is this is not a theoretical
discussion this exists in hardware
it will soon be in product out in the
field and you will soon be experiencing
its benefits excuse me yes we do and we
have already sold samples to customers
in both defense and commercial
applications the technology is not an
amplifier when we did this for the first
three years four years we were doing
this we said it's a polar amplifier and
then everybody said well we just take an
amplifier and put it in front of other
thing everything else and we finally
realized that we just need to stop
calling it an amplifier because while it
technically is kind of sort of maybe an
amplifier it immediately leads everybody
into all of that training that we've all
had for 50 years that if it's an
amplifier then that definition means
it's a linear amplifier and that means I
use it like this and it has the
following kinds of properties and it's
not so about a year ago we had a
formative interaction with a potential
customer which I'll explain a little bit
later and we just said we've got to stop
calling it an amplifier because
immediately that leads them down the
wrong path and we coined this name the
switch mode mixer modulator sm3 that is
actually a much better definition I'll
show you a block diagram as to why it's
actually not an amplifier
as a consequence we are simultaneously
bandwidth efficient spectrum efficient
and power efficient and one of those
essential trades that you face with a
linear amplifier goes away you can have
all three of these simultaneously in a
single device we're going to talk about
what we mean by those because common
knowledge today conflates bandwidth
efficiency with spectrum efficiency and
they're not the same thing let's be
careful about that bandwidth efficiency
says I have a bag that is five megahertz
wide and how much data can i stuff into
my five megahertz bag
that's bandwidth efficiency spectrum
efficiency is I have a chunk of spectrum
that I may be able to bargain for how
effectively can I use that spectrum
we're going to get into that in just a
moment what I'm showing here is an
external measurement of our technology
by keysight laboratories this is 16 384
Klamm 14 bit 14 bits per Hertz to be
particular ok so mostly what you would
experience on your cell phone today is
about 16 km if you're in a really clean
cell zone and you have a really good
receiver on your phone you'll get 64
clamp there dreaming of giving you 256
clamp the only reason we stopped at 16
384 is that's all keysight can measure
our underlying capability is to go to 16
mega clam ok so the game is changing
let's make sure we get that spectrum
efficiency this is the miracle module
you saw earlier just it can
instantaneously change frequency
modulation type and power level
on-the-fly
so if there is an open band it can move
there if the rightful owner of that band
comes up it can leave and go to a
different band this is something that we
have wanted to do for decades power
efficiency this is the experience that
taught us we had to change the name so I
was interacting with a systems customer
a really smart systems customer and
these these guys are really really good
and he said ok I get it you're 50%
efficient generate generating the LTE
downlink single at half watt output
power so that's a 3 watt peak you're 50%
efficient so that means you pull 6 watts
of DC any of you in here see the linear
amplifier thinking embedded in that and
I had to turn to him and I had no no no
50% efficient we're half watt out we
take 1 watt of DC he looked at me like I
he just was convinced that I probably
should run for president of the United
States because I was a very good
salesman or lying take your pick
and that's impossible that's 160 percent
efficient and I sat there and stared at
him for a second and went we have that
existential problem right you're sitting
there going I'm trying to explain to him
that this is not his grandfather's
technology and how do I do that when
I've already led him to believe by
calling it an amplifier that it is so
it's not an amplifier it's absolutely
not an amplifier miracle provides
bandwidth efficiency spectrum efficiency
all-in-one okay you don't have to make a
trade oh I want to actually say
something here if you had a linear
amplifier and you went from 16 crammed
to 256 crammed you'd expect to be able
to do that with the right EVM you'd have
to make an efficiency trade-off so we
take our miracle system
from 16 km to 64 clam to 256 clam to
1024 clam to 4096 gram to 16 384 clam
our efficiency is 50% flat for every
single one ok
there is no tray there are different
traits but not that trait so let's go
into what we always thought software
radio was going to be you have on one
end coming in the RF to digital
converter your receiver now the other
hand you have the digital to RF
converter your transmitter and you do
stuff in the middle okay we don't do any
of the stuff we do the other pieces the
part on the left hand side the receiver
you're really working on 80 bitty little
stuff and trying to pull it out we've
almost got that done the analog to
digital converters that we've been
spending a lot of time on low-noise
amplifiers all the rest of that piece of
what we're doing that we almost have
today from DC delight we can do 100
megahertz 200 megahertz 500 megahertz
digitization x' on the fly it sucks
power it's perhaps not as nice as we'd
like it but we can do it on the right
hand side doesn't work
all right you have essential trade-offs
between bandwidth efficiency to nobility
and power efficiency why we always
wanted this is right one of those
diagrams from one of those essential
papers you may have been the one to do
this
flexible RF hardware okay only problem
is the transmitters aren't if you take
out a linear PA and you look out and
we've categorized a whole bunch of them
you have an essential set of traits and
the trade is I can make it efficient but
narrow
and I can make it wideband but not have
efficiency that's what miracle does by
direct comparison okay it's not a linear
amplifier we're gonna get into the
physics of this in a moment so for those
of you that are bored at this point in
time it will get fun how do we do it two
fundamental enablers gallium nitride
which really for our purposes didn't
come into existence until about 2010
2012 at the frequency ranges of interest
for what we need to do okay and the
switch mode mixer modulator which
followed a direct polar architecture
which had been tried before in the 90s
in silicon and kind of limped to a
partial success with a whole lot of
lessons learned about where the hard
problems were going to be you get out of
the switch mode mixer modulator
incredibly precise signal control as you
saw with 16 384 clamp it's not linear
you don't need linear you need precision
not linearity
let's get that word out of our lexicon
this is the Wolfe speed v5 process it's
going to be released soon so hopefully
this year we've been working with it
with Wolff speed for the last four years
so we have the benefit of having a
incredibly close relationship with the
foundry I will dodge some questions
about exactly what we're doing with the
foundry if you ask them because some of
it is proprietary to us and Coe
proprietary to them so I can't obviously
reveal their stuff but
this is a hundred and forty nanometer
gann hemp the process it's gone on
silicon carbide we're going to go into
what makes this stuff work the real
critical part here is when you're doing
a switch your ft of the technology that
you're working in needs to be at least
ten times the frequency of where you're
going to operate the switch because it's
a square wave and if you can't resolve
the square wave with something like the
ninth harmonic being present in the
square wave it's not a switch it's that
easy no magic if you want to have a
decade of bandwidth ie tuned from 300
megahertz the three gigahertz from 450
megahertz to four and a half gigahertz
you can't have a matching Network we
don't you need to be 50 ohm matched at
the device if you're gonna be 50 ohm
matched at the device and you're gonna
put out 3 watts it's real easy to do the
math ok don't need to go to MIT or
Stanford to be able to do that math
right V squared by 2 R equals 3 R is 50
figure it out right it's not hard okay
so bottom line is if your output
impedance is too low you need to reduce
the load impedance you get more output
power but then when you do the
transformation to come back out you get
squeezed and you're done silicon will
never do this okay gallium arsenide yep
just math okay what you've got there all
right
linear amplifier physics you know it's
one of those things and our CTO is a guy
named Earl McCune and I'm sorry he can't
be here because his mustache alone is
legendary but the bottom line here is is
that everybody tells you all the wonders
of linear amplifiers when you're an
early engineer or physicist and you
never actually sit down and realize that
linear amplifiers are designed to be
inefficient because the principle
operating point for a linear amplifier
is in the peak of the IV curve where
dissipated power is maximum so if you
are absolutely the most linear you can
be you are by definition the most
inefficient you can be so when you think
through that process and you actually
think through what your trades are and
you squeeze these complex signals into
that space you have just a couple of
essential trades that you're faced with
if you're gonna use a linear amplifier
you have a couple of choices this is the
choice if you have an iPhone 8 or an
iPhone 10 or you have some of the other
devices you have this in your phone for
one or two of the bends that your phone
operates on that's a good idea
however you'll notice that the peak
operating point is still the most
inefficient operating point of the
transistor so it's a compromise it's
it's not kissing your sister this is
good science right but you're still
working from a linear amplifier if
you're going to do a switch mode mixer
modulator you're dealing with the same
physics of a transistor but you have a
different circuit architecture
fundamentally different circuit
architecture we call that a direct polar
architecture that polar designation will
be obvious in a moment there is no free
lunch you give away three big challenges
for the
linear amplifier and you take on about
eight for the switch-mode mixer
modulator but if you need to go through
thinking about the Himalayas if you need
to go through three Class six Rapids or
eight Class two Rapids I think I'll pick
the eight class two very much okay if
you're going to reduce power dissipation
this is your essential trade-off if
you're gonna run Class A you're running
in this middle point Class A B you're
still not getting a free lunch if you
want a switch you're going between these
two points and it's just the math you
sit down you look at where your
dissipated power is you look at how fast
you can switch and you work it out no
magic this is what switching looks like
how fast you can switch determines your
dissipated power in the switching time
and your harmonic content and whether
you can be clean transition times have
to be fast there is a premium on having
a low on resistance and small amounts of
capacitance so that the amount of charge
that you need to move back and forth in
the device is small I promise the
physics so please for those of you that
now are not having fun we'll go back to
the other stuff so when you do a switch
mode mixer modulator what you end up
with is an operating curve that looks
like this on the upper left and you have
outputs waves and dissipated power
curves like you see in the lower right
and you can simply sit down and do a
trade off and what your frequency
content is versus your switching time
versus your are on versus your
capacitance and figure out where they're
running a switch mode mixer modulator is
good or bad depending on what you're
trying to do and what process note
technology you have access to
it's not rocket science rocket science
is hard this is easy the knee voltage
this is what the flow diagram looks like
and this is why it's called direct polar
you bring in inq which on our wonderful
little chart look like Cartesian
coordinates you convert them to Rho and
theta polar coordinates you take the
phase you mix it with the frequency and
you end up with a phase modulator driver
going into your final switch and what
that looks like is a train of square
waves act the saturation voltage for the
gate that is at the carrier frequency
phase modulated with the phase module
phase modulation okay what you get with
the amplitude is you come up here and
you just amplify that and then you mix
them together in the final stage now
that sounds easy right nothing up my
left nothing up my right okay
truth in advertising remember I said
eight class two Rapids okay the list is
a little bit longer than for the linear
amplifier right but there's a path you
really have to have very consistent
resistances across your switches it has
to be remarkably consistent because when
you're building that square wave for the
phase modulator if it's not consistent
then you're going to have RC slew
between your switching and they'll
gradually get out of phase with each
other life sucks if that happens okay
that's step one step two um zero is a
problem I mean I think we all did the
math in school and somebody said tell me
what the polar coordinates R of 0 and
then tell me how you get a clean defined
in and out of zero in polar coordinates
that's a problem
bandwidth of going to zero is a problem
because I think we all understand
there's a kind of a infinite pole there
if you go to zero and you flip around
right maintaining the efficiency across
that decade tuning bandwidth means that
everything that you have in your system
needs to look like 50 ohms at all
frequencies so you got to pay attention
don't let anybody move your cheese fast
power slowing for modern signal types
the peak to average power ratio on the
4G signals is such that when you're
looking at output powers and you're
going down and coming back up again
we're putting more and more and more
information content in there and you've
got to be able to really move in terms
of being able to move that around
harmonic power management are you're
coming out with a square wave guys what
are you doing with everything else now
if you do it really really really well
you get 88% of your signal to keep
because that's the fundamental content
and what you've got out there the
efficiency numbers I showed you
previously that's not the switched power
that's the power in the fundamental okay
and then finally one of the things that
is a happy thing so I'm kind of lying to
you that this is one of the ones that's
hard you get a huge benefit in load-pull
for this type of signal it is what we
would refer to as stiff you can't pull
it and I'll explain why switch
resistance consistency you need are on
vs. vgs uniformity or they won't switch
you get a sense as to how many switches
we use each one of these layers is for
switches all right and they're staggered
in series to be able to build up that
square wave to hit this final stage now
this meant we had to go out to look at
all the foundries in the world and
figure out if any of them were good
enough for us to be able to use them and
I'm going to point out just
one manufacturer labeled with a T and we
sampled a bunch of their devices and you
can see various devices here and what
the scatter in those devices look like
and then this red curve is 100
iterations of the device from will speed
that we use and they lay on top of each
other the spread is sub percent with the
fit different foundries emphasize
different characteristics so you can't
take what we do at one place and pick it
up and put it someplace else because
those foundries those Gann foundries
don't control for what will speed
controls okay getting to zero output
magnitude now we're all going to
recognize that we're not mathematicians
I won't tell the joke about a
mathematician and engineer and a
physicist going to a hotel room right
fire breaking out you guys have heard
this right ok good so I don't need zero
zero is a philosophical debate you can
have with a mathematician small enough
is zero and for everything that we have
in any of our constellations 80 DB down
from the main signal is zero where we
were stuck last time was 30 DB when they
tried to do this in the 90s gallium
nitride and a little bit of magic on our
side a little bit of Quentin a little
bit of me and boom we have 80 DB and I
think we say that yes we have a path to
130 DB so 24 bits not a problem until
you get on the receiver side so how do
we do that we cheat okay we do things
that engineers do you solve problems
what we do is we recognize that the RF
driver in this switch mode
Najee is itself a switch mode amplifier
of a sense and all you have to do is
work that side and you can do all of
these things in series technically it's
called product mode so what we are doing
is what every device designer and
circuit designer for 50 or 60 years has
endeavored never to do for 50 years
everybody said we want to be in the
linear domain of the transistor unless
you're making power switches in which
case you come up into the compressed
mode what we do is we start in the
compressed mode and we go into product
mode where the output is actually the
product of the voltages that are being
applied on the gate and the drain which
everybody says don't do and that's
exactly what we do right how do you play
this game it's actually not that hard
we've done as you'll see down here in
the bottom we've already done 40 mega
I'm sorry that's 50 mega Hertz up to 4
gigahertz in a single device you play
details as to what things look like so
we're doing this at 4 gigahertz you have
to worry about the ninth harmonic which
is it 36 gigahertz on a gallium nitride
device with gallium nitride dielectric
constant in the active region most
important thing to get everybody to
realize it's the ground it's not ground
okay ground is a local convenience
you cannot put node zero in your design
code and effectively believe that you
have ground doesn't work that way so
when you end up looking at our final
mimics a lot of people have looked at
them and said this looks lopsided
but yeah I guess if you're looking with
Cartesian eyes it is you have to think
about what the electron sees that's not
the same so how does power scale
understand everything down here is the
driver
that's your phase modulator okay that's
the power stage this is a 3 watt device
driver is about 10 times larger than the
power stage the power mixer so you can
go to 10 times higher power and you're
only gonna use twice the amount of gab
okay it does not scale linearly and some
proofs you can do anyway it's a
software-defined radio for God's sakes
digits come in anyway for him you want
goes out we finally got a hold of the 5g
in our waveform we got a hold of it on a
Wednesday we plugged it in on Thursday
and out comes the 5g on our waveform to
spec perfect it's the software-defined
radio but it's doing it at power there
isn't a linear amplifier on the other
end so everything we as engineers wanted
a software-defined radio to do this does
there have been some classic issues with
unipolar amplifiers and drain lag
sometimes referred to as back gating is
one of them this is a classic
measurement out of n I done I think in
2012 you take this type of Drive signal
you put it into a hemp and you find are
two types of effects you see these short
spikes at the beginning and you see a
gradual recovery in the amplitude of the
square wave over time what that's coming
from is the fact that
the carriers are not being swept that
completely out of the active region and
so I have a dynamic impedance for the
different frequencies and as a
consequence I can't get nice clean
signals as I'm slamming all over the
place for these complex modulations
that's the switch mode mixer modulator
that eridan has developed now I'm going
to be truthful we have not eliminated
drain lag the dragon has not been slain
okay we've just arranged that the dragon
take up residence someplace else not
where we want to operate so we've
negotiated with the dragon a little bit
and moved it into a neighborhood that
we're not interested in and as a
consequence there is a very simple
method to produce any complex signal
there is no feedback distortion required
right otherwise why do this I take the
same signal here so what you've got is
you've got this Drive signal coming in
in the gold and you've got the output
coming out in the blue and I'm showing
you that there is no long term delay and
I'm showing you that there is no spike
on the leading edge of the square waves
this is the output of the this is the
digitally synthesized what should be
coming out of the amplifier this is the
IKE this is the MATLAB of the IQ going
in and this is the output from the sm-3
at power at three watts coming out okay
I'm not showing you any intermediate
stages at peak up here okay do the math
yes we'll go into the details
part of this is looking at your very
fast frequency synthesizer and being
able to move really quickly the sm-3
moves as fast as whatever frequency
coming into it moves okay
so we can do end to end in about ten
microseconds and within an octave in
less than two microseconds so that's
almost a mega hop per second the real
detail here is if you're going to be
using an unused band a whitespace band
and you need to get the hell out of
Dodge because the rightful user of that
band popped up you can be out before
they ever even know you're there right
your receiver has got to be looking
cognitive radios so now you're gonna get
into a space called CR cognitive radios
dynamic spectrum access there are I want
to be careful not to step on other
people's property with respect to
cognitive radio algorithms etc so you
would typically be looking at a hundred
to 200 megahertz band and being and say
I'm gonna work here and I have these
three other stations that I have
pre-populated and ready to go to and so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
look here and know that somebody's not
coming in and I'm going to look here
here and here so that if I have to move
I already know where I'm going
and you're transmitting how do you know
that he's on the pan if you're T if
you're staying in that band and you're
TDD your receiver is gonna see something
coming in that's not your modulation
most of these outer bands single bands
for your FTD you need a hell of a lot
more band space and if you're sliding
into a seven megahertz television band
you don't have room to be FTD it's silly
to be FTD if you're doing that okay you
need to get rid of those harmonics
everybody wants to have a flat filter
but you don't need a flat filter okay
you know you're building the filter you
know where the ripples of the filter are
you move the filter around where you're
going your insertion loss on that filter
can be tiny okay something less than
point three D be immune to load pull
I've done a bunch of radar work in my
career phased-array work or if you want
to think about it massive my mo work
when the guys found this they're like
yeah okay fine and I was like no no no
no you don't understand how this is this
is huge
sorry for that
we don't need Isolators because you're a
switch the back EMF from the backward
propagating wave coming transmitter
number one transmitter number two output
output well that output can reverse
couple through that horn and that
electric field coming backward incident
on this transistor is an electric field
which creates a voltage which will slew
a linear amplifier okay we're not a
linear amplifier we give a crap
we're either on in which case we're a
quarter of an ohm rough
as a consequence what you get out of
that is an effective 22 to 32 DB of
isolation from that backward propagating
wave which is all you ever get out of an
isolator except Isolators are frequency
narrow now you have the ability to make
a true phased array massive MIMO system
which is frequency agile can't do that
until you do this the other big thing is
that because you're a switch you don't
amplify a noise out of band
think about that big problem with a
linear amplifier that amplifies
everything I mean you want that if you
don't amplify everything you get
criticized but then realize you do
amplify everything switch you don't do
you amplify what only is coming in at
your signal so the interesting thing
here is you amplify phase noise so you
want to be really thoughtful about what
your frequency synthesizer looks like
you do not amplify amplitude noise right
fundamentally different characteristic
in terms of how you think about how you
build communication signals going
forward okay measurement just how good
are you at that our phase noise coming
in from our carrier has about 70
megahertz plus/minus a bandwidth so we
go outside of that we do a spot check or
about 3 DB above KT okay we look at that
measurement and kind of go it's low we
don't believe that it's 3 DB we don't
believe our measurement accuracy at 3 dB
all we know is it's a hell of a lot
lower than anything else that's ever
been done other benefits of the switch
mode mixer modulator you get inherent
stabilities you cannot oscillate not a
possibility your switch you're in Gann
so you're thermally stable we have
inadvertently
tested that so I'm not outing anybody am
i I think I'm okay we tested it first
nevermind the founder that now works
from Croatia to escape my wrath but it
worked great manufacturing stability you
have a huge are on 250 ohms Delta so if
there's a little bit variation in our on
you don't care we've built most a
thousand of these devices at this point
in time and we have 100% yield okay
long-term operating stability it's gone
it's a rock it doesn't care it's a
switch it doesn't care now implications
yeah I just knocked out five hundred
percent yield yes are we that's after
sort sides and they have to do a visual
inspection of their parts so if they see
that there's like a metal flake or
something like that in the process at
three five process but after they sort
at that level which is probably yeah
maybe a maybe two or three percent loss
maybe after that every part we've ever
tried has behaved identical and in fact
we use the same correction tables across
all our diet so we do a linear
correction tables or to get to make
sixteen three four you have a
feed-forward linear correction you're
all again you haven't liked the change
sir
thank you sometimes what you thought
we're gonna be class two Rapids turns
out to be calm water you know luck is
always better than skill dynamic
spectrum access what do we mean by this
and what is it going to emphasize it's
not going to emphasize the bandwidth
efficiency you're not really trying to
pump more data into the same channel
what you're trying to do is move to
where they're not and use spectrum more
efficiently why is that a chance
this is what we're all used to right
we've seen this map I don't care how
many incarnations of this map we've seen
it's a lie
okay that's perception why is that
perception people did a measurement of
New York and Chicago in 2012 this is the
actual occupancy and this is an
overstatement of the occupancy because
if a band was touched by its rightful
occupant in a ten-minute slice it was
dictated as being occupied for the
entirety of that ten minutes some mark
you could have come in and made a
30-second transmission and that entire
ten minutes is checked off as being
owned okay so you kind of look at that
and you lay that on top of the other one
and you look at it you kind of go down
there's a lot of white space out there
now let's be honest some of that white
space is out of bounds okay
there's stuff that's in there that would
be really really unwise to step on
things like aircraft localization
indicators or FAA broadcast or police
and fire etc those are hard square keep
out zones but there's large chunks in
there that are for the television
station backlinks or this is a really
fun one that I'm still struggling to try
to understand I think I understand how
we got here the entire television space
is blocked off now the reason we do that
is because we have channel 3 in San
Francisco and we have something else in
San Jose and we have something else in
Sacramento and they can't step on each
other but if you could use the empty
channels in San Francisco or the empty
channels in San Francisco and just move
around and be clean enough with your
noise out-of-band that you don't step on
people that you're not supposed to step
on all of a sudden something on the
order of three or four hundred megahertz
comes into play and at an approximate
value of a billion dollars a megahertz
for license there's there's a lot of
reason to go use that if you could
technology today can't
because you'd have to be able to move
depending on what the local television
space looked like and it's not
affordable to do that because I'd have
to cram your phone with about another
six or seven different amplifiers which
you would not take and you would not
want to pay for but if your amplifier
does it anyways excuse me
your switch mode mixer modulator does it
anyways okay
WTF right let's go get it done now to
drive this home we all drove here some
of you may have been fortunate enough to
walk here some of you might have biked
here but sooner or later we're gonna get
in the car and drive and when you get
out on that Highway unless you're really
unfortunate you are allowed to change
lanes now I want you to think about this
model of what we do here we're in
channel B we've got ten users maybe
dividing up 100 megabits per second a
channel C they only have five users
channel a they didn't do good marketing
they have no users but they have 100
megabit per second channel it's sitting
there empty and the way we operate today
is like getting on the highway and you
have a license to drive only in the
first Lane you get a license to drive in
the second lane you're not allowed to
change lanes wouldn't it be awesome if
we could take the high traffic channel
move it over to the low traffic channel
and give everybody the maximum access
that they could have at that moment in
time
right you'd love to be able to do that
that's what dynamic spectrum access is
okay we can't do that with the hardware
we have today you can now can't do that
with narrowband efficient efficient pas
miracle does that I've already walked
you through that massive mind mo this is
going to be beneath you sorry but I had
to start someplace if you take a
standard antenna and I got Annabelle
Grandma and Charlie and I'm sending out
my signal to Grandma everything goes out
radially the same freaking signal goes
to every one of them occupying the
bandwidth
and if my signal to grandma takes up all
the bandwidth Annabelle and Charlie get
squat okay obviously we don't do that we
simply slow down how much grandma can
have mass of my mo is essentially a
phased array that's how I think of
massive MIMO and what it allows you to
do is beam for me it's simple
and Annabelle Grandma and Charlie each
get their full five megahertz it's that
simple
we can do this now there's a problem
however first that envelope tracking
scenario can't do that in a phased array
they have some problems controlling the
phase from an envelope tract amplifier
in order to be able get the precision
phase control to be able to beam steer
what you need to be able to do so you
can't do that you can not do the
envelope tracking but then you're gonna
be six percent efficient instead of
twenty five percent efficient and the
heat problem I'm about to show you gets
a hell of a lot worse this is a Doherty
amplifier twenty five percent is
generous I think the world record for
this particular type of technology right
now is about twenty two percent but but
let's before we're thinking let's give
them credit for ten twenty percent more
you put a heatsink around all four sides
that's not what they do but let's get a
measure of how hard this problem is what
you're gonna find is those elements in
the center generally you can let them
get to about 85 C and they'll still work
if you didn't have a really good cooling
solution they're getting to 235 C so you
have a hundred and fifty degrees C
thermal challenge that's the way I want
you to think about this now we've
already demonstrated that we can do
forty percent at least under these
conditions depending on what they're
trying to do we may be available to be
at about fifty to sixty percent
let's take 40 we're at a hundred and
thirty five see with no heat sinking
that's not the right measure the measure
is 50 degrees C above 85 150 above 85 50
above 85 I think we all understand 150
is not three times as hard it's a hell
of a lot harder than that
so this is opening that door and you're
getting that efficiency with something
can do all of those complex signals to
do all of that beam steering at once
maximizing the data rate okay
there is a false conception that
bandwidth equals data it's even gotten
into our words how much bandwidth you
have I don't know 100 megabits per
second that's not frickin bandwidth guys
okay bandwidth is measured in Hertz
that's data rate and there's a false
perception that carrier aggregation
solves this problem carrier aggregation
doesn't solve this problem it makes it
worse I take a wider bandwidth signal
okay
I just used more frequency and then i
pair it with another piece of signal
someplace and I just made that harder
because now I've got to actually take
more edges off to deconvolve that and
get my data out if I actually look at
the net efficiency of that process it
goes down this is what we've already
done right that's the signal I showed
you at the beginning you just go right
by the process of what you're doing if
you want to do the comparison 16 384
qualm the signal what we've already done
16 km 64 km 256 clamp yes sir the reason
nobody does 16 384 12 or 16 million
qualms like I said before it has nothing
to do with the amplifiers its instead of
this challenge law makes it completely
impractical to do that in correct and
I'll prove that to you in a moment so if
you go and do 24 bits you can't even see
the dots anymore and 16 384 cram is
where 16 used to be there's your array
that you want to worry about
okay now you're right if I want to do 24
bits in a mobile cellular system not
going to do that but if I want to do 24
bits in a point-to-multipoint system
where I have a static
receiver and I have a static transmitter
and I'm about 800 meters away and I
generate the gain that I need between
those two signals and for 24 bits I need
about 63 DB of gain in my structure 63
DB of signal to noise margin I can
easily do that okay I'm gonna leave that
off for the moment no there's pieces
that I'm not in a position we've got ten
patents that have issued we're gonna
have to leave some of these things to
the reader to figure out correct and the
receiver is not issued okay this is just
for fun we all most of us I see some of
you that are gonna look at this and go
who the hell are those people on the
screen okay for those of you that don't
know on the upper left is the Star Trek
Enterprise it was a TV show that played
from about 1967 to 1970 crossed a bunch
of racial barriers I think we had the
first biracial kiss on screen a bunch of
that kind of stuff okay I'm sorry I'm
off a little bit there and they had this
amazing communicator that everybody
looked at and said that's science
fiction until we came out with these
things right everybody's still wondering
how in the heck they stand up there and
geo up in space and just come down and
they can talk to all these people at the
same time you just look at the size of
that main dish and you can pull out the
numbers it's about 525 meters across and
you can look at how many massive MIMO
arrays you can put on that sucker and of
course I mean you do have a plasma
reactor in there so I think God's sakes
you don't you don't worry for power do
the link calculation and you've got
about a hundred and thirty-five DB of
margin so you don't have any problem
whatsoever
all right bottom line out of all of this
is that the game has changed the
technology has changed what you can and
cannot do in terms of moving the Lynx
forward in getting that process out has
changed you'll see this in products
within the next three to five years I'm
happy to take any more questions precise
on the upload of your switch your mixes
with Madison
if I did not make that clear let me try
no we don't
it's a feed-forward system only we
represented and seen you have a DAC
sends its data to an amplifier that
amplifier has feedback it's it's
narrowband systems and the amplitude
packets in there bad system so it's very
you can get 50 60 DB of linearity no
problem let's go through this for a
moment there's there's two or three
pieces to your answer all right so so
let's be careful the first is all of the
nonlinearities in the system and there
are many all right there is amplitude
nonlinearities there are phase
nonlinearities and there are amplitude
phase coupled nonlinearities the beauty
of the gallium nitride system is they
are all as Quentin pointed out earlier
measurable and incredibly reproducible
so the first thing is is that when we
get inq and we convert that to Rho and
theta the first thing we do is we know
these are the Rho and theta that the
customer the dude on the left has asked
for that then converts into as he just
indicated a lookup table of these
than the values that we are sending out
because we know these combinations of
values lead to those values all right so
that's the first thing that is the
feed-forward nature of this gets to that
now there is going to do layers within
layers within layers I apologize but I'm
trying to give you the actual correct
answer this is the other part of the
answer right we're doing the physics
thing right this is the first truth I'm
sorry I lied to you as a freshman
classical mechanics okay now I'm going
to tell you about relativity I'm sorry
now you're a junior I'm gonna lie to you
again and tell you about quantum and oh
sorry now I'm gonna lie to you again in
graduate school and tell you about
relativistic quantum right so I'm just
trying to peel the layer back each time
so the first thing that you need to
understand is its IQ goes to row theta
goes to a feed-forward lookup table all
right now in this diagram we're showing
you something called a lamb all right
the lamb is the feedback piece that
Quentin was talking about it is we are
sending this signal in we want this
voltage to be applied to the drain of
the sm-3 and we need to apply that
voltage exquisitely precise okay and so
as that voltage comes in the lamb is
this green line and it is on a feedback
circuit locally it's not looking at the
RF output it's looking at the voltage
it's producing compared to the voltage
it was commanded to produce okay and
that's where the feedback is there is no
feedback coming from the RF clear the
bandwidth of that feedback right now is
about a hundred megahertz okay
and yes there are things that you would
want to do to increase that for very
very greedy things that you would like
to be able to do
the road yes very local think of it as a
sort of ball where you're probing the
star spot where it's a little bit of a
lie but not much okay
I you know sitting down in drawing
circuit diagram just how much you're
right right I think yes sir I'll do
better than that
I'll send Berk okay he with the mustache
okay
he knows the receiver upside down inside
out and backwards the challenge you have
on the receiver so let's let's actually
talk through that for a moment before I
take your question the challenge you
have on the receiver right now is it
makes no sense commercially to deliver
24 bits per Hertz you get no credit for
it you get no value for it so
commercially what it makes sense to do
today is to roll out eight bits per
Hertz give everybody eight bits per
Hertz compared to four bits per Hertz
that they have today you double their
bandwidth I don't know about you but if
somebody it spurts then you double their
data rate
excuse me Thank You sensei I'm sorry
they do it to me all the time to they
the word amplifier still comes out of my
mouth they throw things at me okay you
know I'm I'm old it's hard to teach so
um probably come out with eight bits to
start with get everybody up to eight
bits the beauty of what we've done is
that moving from eight bits to ten bits
to twelve bits to 14 bits to sixteen
bits is mostly a firmware change and a
receiver change the receiver that will
go in will have more capability than we
will initially harvest so there will be
eight to ten years worth of lifetime and
anything that we do just in firmware and
we can simply roll those out over time
as local conditions ask for more data
okay yeah well it's me also I got a
whole bunch of questions but I'm what's
the comic line I'm here all night cells
Oh hmm so okay so gang devices I think
it's been established that there are
high high efficiency and my voltage and
high linearity for quite some time and
polar amplifiers have been around a long
time I built one in an RFIC 20 years
first polar amplifier was built in 1917
yes so you haven't really told what
specifically eridan is doing that's that
it's different other that's the same
sort of it's packed this can is being
done by by the transition I mean I'm
sorry I thought I existed I'm sorry I
thought I did that well no okay hold on
a second I'm gonna go to one thing that
we have done which independent of your
value the Patent Office established its
own category for it nobody everybody has
always lectured for sixty years to avoid
what we're doing okay there are many
many many patents taught art to avoid
product mode and that is what we're
doing okay you can't do what we're doing
if you don't do product mode if you
don't do product mode you won't get 80
DB you won't get 130 DB you won't do LTE
you won't do 5g you won't do my mouth so
I don't believe there's any currently
operating systems are 80 DB you don't
need 80 DB because you're thinking of a
linear amplifier you need you're saying
you talk about how you're gonna go to
130 ah I'm sorry you're missing why
that's important why that's important is
because as you go to more and more
complex signals you need better and
better and more precise definition
of where you are the issue is that it
just just to use an example if you have
some system that is currently in
operation and it takes X amount of power
to get a certain number of bits per
second per let's say it takes 100
milliwatts together yeah and you're able
to do Q Quang to 56 right because you
have a real channel with thermal noise
so you it takes 100 milliwatts if you're
gonna go to qualms 16 384 the power is
going to be in the kilowatts in order to
do that right no matter humbly grandpa
my Reno's thermal noise Joe you're
working against true so I'm going to
simply ask you that we take this offline
because we have lots of data on systems
where with thermal noise and white noise
processing on the receive side you can
gain another 30 40 DB this is not
speculation this is being done DARPA
funded an entire program in that space
it's done alright we're talking about
harvesting technologies that were
demonstrated 10 years ago so this is not
speculation I don't need to develop a
new receiver topology everything I just
gave to you is all done on the Digital
side all right it's not it's not magic
all right it exists now does that get
you to 24 bits probably not today it
probably gets you to between 16 and 18
bits done then you've got more work to
do what you've done and what I'm trying
to evangelize for lack of a better
description is that linear amplifier has
gone down this path as far as we are
concerned we believe the linear
amplifier is a dead end on the
transmitter okay it's a dead end
right if you go down a different path
you can open up a different set of
traits which we have been able to
demonstrate opens up a different trade
off envelope for a system optimization
if you're looking at this from the
standpoint of a 5g system we're doing 5g
already in a way that linear amplifier
guys cannot do today it's that simple
and we're a tiny company with a tiny
amount of funding compared to massive
companies out there that have been
trying to do linear amplifiers for 50
years that's all you're saying well I I
think it's not just efficiency okay
we'll take it off thank you sir 5g gonna
be range yeah how distance frequency
does a terrain a distance oh good boy
what frequency hold what breezes will we
get operate on that's a damn good
question right now if you if if your ass
that's a question for the FCC not me
the if you ask the bigs they will tell
you we're going to 28 we're going to 39
we're going to 60 gigahertz the reason
they are doing that is because they have
two existential challenges with the way
they're doing what they've got the first
is given the linear amplifier technology
they're using they have a limited
ability to drive the a CLR roll-off
therefore they need to find frequency
allocations where they have the space
not to step on their neighbors and as a
consequence they're going up there the
minute for those of us that have done
microwaves and I've done everything from
ka-band up to 600 gigahertz there are
some problems as you go up in frequency
like drywall all of a sudden becomes a
barrier to your energy which is not a
happy thing if you don't have a
transmitter in the closet you walked
into inadvertently so range I don't know
because if
four gigahertz massive MIMO 256 by 256
the design specs that I've seen coming
from folks like Nokia Ericsson etc
they're targeting three kilometres okay
the design specs for point-to-multipoint
links at higher data rates they're
targeting 800 meters well it depends
what you're trying to do and the reason
I'll make the latter point is where I
live in the center of San Francisco I
have one choice of cable provider today
I want to get your heads off of mobile
telephony okay I have one choice of
cable provider which happens to be a
subsidiary of the evil Comcast right and
I could pick anybody I could say evil
AT&T I could say evil charter because I
don't think anybody that has a cable
provider is happy with them and the
reason you only get one I'll appeal to
my VC friend is business
they come in they put in the cable and
they get I don't know however many
people they get 70% of the neighborhood
whoever is going to pay to put in a
second cable data has shown they get 30%
of whatever the first guy did
so there are oh I by definition is three
times lower so if you didn't put it in
first there is no business reason to put
in a second cable ergo there is no
competition
ergo you're screwed so the first thing
that I figured out when we started
seeing this is um within 800 meters of
my home and I'm in the center of San
Francisco I'll grant you that
within 800 meters of my home there are
840 gigabit per second plus fiber data
points okay and not from the big four
some from the big four some from others
okay now the closest one to me and I'll
grant you that I probably would not
select them as my internet provider is
PG&E that has a 40 gigabit per second
fiber link going into a substation as I
pointed out right going into a
substation that has a hundred kilobits
of usage but the
mandated to have the fiber in there so
they have 39 plus gigabits of free
bandwidth that fiber is 127 meters from
my house
yes I've measured it so if I did my link
with a massive mite with a 256 by 256
massive MIMO antenna going to my home at
4 gigahertz my absolute Shannon limited
link to that position something on the
order of 18 to 20 bits per Hertz 256
it's an array 16 by 16 array to 56
transmit 256 receive now sometimes they
will advertise it at 256 by 512 they'll
have 256 transmitters and 512 receivers
with cross polarization okay so I
there's a lingo that that massive MIMO
is developing yes sir
did I answer your question yeah sorta
try again
okay how about okay so I want to answer
before I move on what can they get
spectrum and 4 gigahertz oh yes
there's a there's a butt ton of spectrum
from about 3/7 up god 3 7 2 4 3 3 7 2
for 2 there's there's it's and
particularly locally this is the other
thing that is kind of miraculous if if
you can actually control your edges and
by that I mean your spectral crap that
you leak out and if you can control your
beamforming if you're a massive MIMO
antenna then there's tons of spectrum
available to you okay and that is really
that's the game here is going back to
looking at that spectrum diagram and
recognizing that if you can go where
they aren't so if you could be dynamic
which massive MIMO would not need to be
or if you can control your footprint
there's lots of room for you to work
below 6 gigs so there is a discussion
going on this is this is open and on the
table to my knowledge there is a
discussion going on with the FCC from
3.7 all the way up to 4.2 500 megahertz
bandwidth
yeah okay okay I've better than here
it's Beckett okay that's a lot yeah okay
sir we hit an EE 380 speaker I'm
guessing maybe 20 years ago telling us a
whole lot of wireless communications and
new protocols and such and such and
reducing antenna size and putting
incentive on ships and radio between
ships and so forth he explained that the
technology should work but technically
it was in violation of federal law to do
what he's proposing and he said that the
license pd's we expect to collect on
these patents should easily cover the
lobbying of the FCC if you're
broadcasting on a channel and then the
rightful owner comes along you can back
off yeah let me before he even knows
you're there ya know I'm what I'm
actually what I'm actually advocating
the FCC is doing I so let me let me let
me go through something called dice ban
so you know what it's doing and just
make sure that you understand that what
we're talking about is dice ban on
simply more than steroids okay so the
first experiment they've done and this
is actually laughable just so you
understand what I'm about to tell you
the first experiment they did they did
in the aan spy-1 radar band which I
believe is 1922 1960 megahertz now
what's really unique is that in the
United States the spy-1 radar band is
blocked out throughout the United States
now this is a radar that goes on ships
okay this is the aegis radar right now
we're a forward-thinking country I think
sometimes and and we have Fargo North
Dakota with the Aegis spy-1 keep out so
good so why do we have that keep out
well the reason we have that keep out is
because the Aegis cruisers use their
radars to map where the shore is
as they approach the coast and so we
thought we I'm sorry we the country
thought that it was a good experiment to
do dynamic spectrum access to allocate
ten megahertz channels from 1920 to 1960
and have sensors along the coast to see
if an Aegis was in range in which case
they would use a master controller to
shut off those bands and everybody who
was in those bands would have to vacate
those bands there's an entire I Triple E
community dedicated to doing experiments
in this space and some of you may be
involved in that if you're not I
encourage you to because they need wise
minds what's that the the thing that
they've done so far is they've done an
experiment on the East Coast the United
States for the last two years where they
have made those bands available and
they're doing and dice pick the dice ban
protocol which is going through the FCC
for approval has three types of users
right it has primary licensed user if
the primary licensed user is in the
space nobody else is allowed in the
space if you're in the space you must
vacate the space in get this folks get
this folks how fast do we think is
reasonable to vacate that band 90
seconds okay they're setting a really
high bar okay 90 seconds okay
90 seconds okay now there is a secondary
licensed user okay
a secondary licensed user can be in the
band if the primary licensed user is not
in the band
and they kick everybody else out okay
and then there is a third tier of user
that is called a general access user who
pays the least fees if the primary or
secondary are not there then the general
access users may have access okay this
structure has been running it's not
thought right it's not concept yeah
it took the SCC 13 years to get there
okay because honestly I will tell you
the technology didn't exist and really
it wasn't even the radio technology it
was the management technology be able to
figure out you're in you're out you're
in you're out and communicating all of
that general access uses it's a
first-come first-served
okay in-out in-out you know and they
actually do that across the bands so if
you get booted out of the ten band you
move into the 20 band move into the 30
band moving the 40 band in Reverse and
they have the cognitive radio algorithms
already eight
let me rephrase I said algorithms plural
they have an algorithm running
we won't debate whether it's a good
algorithm or bad algorithm the best
algorithm that is way so far outside my
expertise I'm not gonna even comment on
it but I will say it works pays the
least these does everybody is paying
these to humble you license band from
uncle okay that's that's where you how
you license access today okay and the
fees that for a two seconds the fees for
a general access user are about a factor
of 50 lower than the fees for a
secondary user that is about a factor of
10 lower than the fees for a primary
user that's what the experiment has
shown so far in the bidding now whether
that holds its factor 500 that's not
small okay so if that holds as you move
up there's a whole dialogue of what the
economics look like yes finally I'm
sorry to make you keep
I'm trying to figure out how I can
answer your question without pouting
things oh no no no no we are we are
actively in discussions with three very
large companies in three very different
spaces that have asked that question for
obvious reasons right I think every
single one of those applications would
say that five years down the road they
want to have access to at least a
hundred million units per quarter okay
obviously depending on success right so
one of the first things we have to show
them is how do you do a hundred million
units per quarter and does that require
you know the amount of power that it
because the will speed foundry is in
Research Triangle Park North Carolina
and that's presumed to be the bottleneck
because the silicon ASIC is presumed not
to be the bottleneck that's a correct
assumption but we will speed is already
getting ready to build a six in actually
is in the process of building a six inch
line and our requirements these are tiny
die and they will get tiny or still the
die that we're using our research died
and Quentin because our lead gand
designer is profligate with making sure
we have lots of places to test things
which is good because we make mistakes
it's good to measure and as a
consequence go to production that die
size is going to go down to maybe a
millimeter and a half by a millimeter
maybe a millimeter and a half by a
millimeter and a half so we're using six
square milliliters today it goes down to
two square millimeters we will use about
the third 1/3 of the capacity of the
six-inch line for a hundred million
units per quarter okay it's not
that that's not the challenge I please
God let that be the challenge I will be
a very happy man okay yeah and I given
what so I understand that and I
understand the question on on
manufacturing yield and and and those
pieces we were concerned when we got
started five years ago four years ago
that we'd start with like 10% yields and
if you had 10% yields and you had all of
these problems then why the hell you do
this and so we were we were focusing
like hawks on what our early yields were
gonna be and we grilled Quentin
regularly what he'd done were they were
they cherry-picking the chips that were
coming off of the the will speed foundry
because nothing everything worked
nothing broke until we deliberately
started breaking things right I mean
because we're engineers we we break
things that's what we do and and we were
just we were stunned at what our yields
were and that shifted our thinking and
quite honestly a shifted the foundries
thinking to in terms of what they could
do to move their process to something
that allowed them to have greater wafer
yields so simultaneously what we've seen
in four years is the price per square
millimeter come down by almost a factor
of seven and our yield remain at a
hundred percent our costed yield because
the stuff that they don't ship us they
eat okay so that's I mean on the gans
side it's stunning
that's all right and and that's one of
the benefits you get with a switch
compared to a linear amplifier because
you're not looking at transconductance
you're operating here and here and it
either is or it isn't it's a zero one
criteria there's not bins of it's gotten
this G sub M and that C or anything else
it's in or it's out anything else yes
sir
the in recent years business interest
there was recently a documentary
produced I'm hitting the Mars
involvement another video security
techniques are you at all familiar with
the full story there what is your
reaction on them I'm not familiar with
the story I have let's see I we didn't
we didn't I know my bio was sent out but
I should in full disclosure tell you
that I was formerly a chief scientist
and program manager at DARPA and as a
consequence of one of my programs I
deployed into the field with a Special
Forces aviation unit for 15 months so I
had extraordinarily personal familiarity
with the 45 pounds of radio and 38
pounds of body armor that I got to wear
at 127 degrees in 9,000 feet so you take
a very personal learning to two things a
frequency-hopping
saves your freakin life a second if I
could have all of those radios and
something that looked like this lots of
big hairy strongmen would want to kiss
you okay because it would make a big
deal frequency-hopping is a lifesaver
there's no other way to put it I believe
some program this week on PBS is very
good frequency-hopping actually I don't
know when it started started but the
first time we were dealing with it was
in World War 2 yeah I Triple E spectrum
had an article about her he goes 1989
it's easily looked up she is named
doesn't that
by Robert Schultz sir is there anything
known more than just being is bigger
story about the new Apple very high bad
high-bandwidth personal radio system if
I did know anything I wouldn't be in a
position to talk about it one of the
reasons there are taboo slots in the
television ban is because of the for
selectivity of early receivers is that
problem gone away television receivers
or radio receivers so if you're using
digital television which everybody does
today the receiver technology changed if
you don't have enough selectivity in the
DTV you never get the DTV signal so the
selectivity changed by about 40 DB when
you went to DTV okay how tube and
selectivity you refer to Jason channel
rejection say yes we're just using the
same definition yeah that's one more
question about the drive the drive
suspect we have feedback to district
determined precisely the level it sounds
like you have a very low impedance
voltage follower that is what actually
drives out is that really what what
you've got in the sense the fact it's in
so we can talk about it you can think of
it it's a common story on an op amp and
the dumb of the source follower you have
a buck converter it sets to four sets of
voltage levels you have a small voltage
difference voltage regulator to
basically have a variable voltage
voltage regulator and you have feedback
from that source all over coming back
and on your op map so you're always
holding that right voltage on a circuit
that's switching very very quickly
across and then mixing point is to choke
right on the other side of the choke
it's mixing so because you know the
voltage very precisely on the top of
that choke and you're regulating it with
60 DB or more of feedback based game all
right
you can get very very precise signals so
this also
suspiciously like an amplifier to me
people know you're going to switch since
when is saying so on top of the lamb so
the lamb isn't out too far yeah dad dad
isn't out too far yeah yeah that's my
amplitude modulator amplifier that's
just amplifying the amplitude signal
right but the actual supplied for that
that that source follower the drain side
of it milk is a buck converter it's
basically like an envelope tractor
that's the right way to think about it
so there's a booth one bolt of overhead
in there okay now that one bolt of
overhead and the switching point it all
gives you that really nice elegant
system that's really really efficient so
we were thinking with the drain
efficiency you know you didn't take the
drain efficiency that source follower
efficiency and the buck converter that
stack up
that's basically the efficiencies Doug
is talking about thanks to DC to RF
conversion efficiency and including the
driver portion of the PA so yeah that is
an amplifier up top and technically the
face modulator is an amplifier - right
so what you've chosen to do is you've
chosen to take one linear amplifier
break it into two very different
amplifiers align them in time to
picoseconds and mix them that's what
you've done they don't convolve just
perfectly yes sir
what kind of minute minimum geometries
do you need on your chip 149 bad what we
you asked a question and I'm gonna give
you that answer and then I'm gonna tell
you the question you should have asked
and okay that's an even better day yeah
so what we need to do what we're doing
is a hundred and forty nanometers we are
evaluating additional approach what
would we really like about seventy to
ninety nanometers
be the ultimate place that we would like
to be able to see this because then we
as we look at it and we do all of the
trades that's what would push us up into
the maximum capability for this
technology in these six gigahertz
envelope and and do it with just just
just painfully good efficiency if we
look at the 60 gigahertz band that's a
different technology note that's
probably not gam okay you go up there
you need to have a 600 gigahertz
technology capability there are other
options to do that and you'd be at a
lower power point okay and it's self
securing because it's atmospheric will
be absorbing yeah okay so there that
strictly that that 600 that 60 gigahertz
signal is strictly for
point-to-multipoint broadcast and
getting away from the cable guys that's
the only thing it's good for you're
gonna do that inside a house go home
yeah right somebody chooses to boil
noodles in the kitchen and the kitchen
will be off-limits because the water
vapor will absorb all the signal I mean
it's it's nuts it's nuts
it's nuts I I we were doing some tests
earlier in my career on a Navy ship and
we were trying and we were in Hawaii and
we'd made it work in Virginia Beach in
November and we went to Hawaii and it
didn't work
gosh what's different right I mean it's
just that much of a humidity change and
it went from we can almost get it to
work - yeah it's not even getting off
the deck of the ship
so any other questions yes ma'am sir
Hays is not decided by a lookup table
what you're doing is you're taking inq
and you're bringing it in and you're
converting that to what the Rho and
theta are and then that goes into a
lookup table of eight parameters seven
parameters
we're talking you know we got the whole
I'm talking all the voltages and
everything else that come out of Rho and
theta that we then send forward there's
about three centers there's three tables
above 4096 points in each table talking
we're not where cross we're cross
convolving your answer here we have
about we have a half a dozen things that
we control out of that knowing what
those controls need to be we know what
the answer needs to be we know what the
nonlinearities are that's a little
cupcake okay there are multi remember
what the driver looks like there's seven
stages to the driver remember that we
are playing games inside the driver to
do product mode so there are multiple
signals that are coming out of that
depending on what you're doing if you
have the base path that enter phase
changes or the amplitude changes so if
the amplitude changes on that choke - we
talked about earlier and it gets really
low we'll go into this product mode the
phase will change this thing so we have
a correction linear direct lookup table
- corrects the phase as you change the
open power I know if that's what you're
asking
yeah hello and that - actually happens
to pull very accurately across all the
checks but what's the resolution about
the base paths so we want it in time or
you want it in in frequency and so like
how what level do we correct phase we
corrected one point two degrees would
you tell me what you mean by product
mode sure what we mean by product mode
is the best way to show that to you
simple it multiplies so if you use as
you changed if you can
change the voltage on the train or you
change the voltage on the gate do is to
actually come together so part of that
not Doug being explained the what you're
doing I so a 101 201 301 right what what
you're doing here I showed all these
voltages being the same that's not what
we do
I told you I was lying to you so what we
do is in product mode is we reduce this
amplitude we reduce the amplitude of the
signal going into the gate and that's
the 201 line the 301 line is that us
showed you the driver that has multiple
stages we actually reduce the voltages
at multiple stages in the driver in
order to accomplish this without too
much swing for lack of a better
description yeah I mean curves about
trimester yeah right as you slide down
the gate bolt you need to drive the gate
laughs no I understand what you're
saying so you're compensating for this
interaction happen twice itself
absolutely I understand absolutely
that's what we're doing and that's what
product mode is and that's how you get
enough vertical resolution that when you
do sixteen 384 clam and you're in near
zero
you have 0.4% EVM which is in that
signal that I was showing you we're at
their measurement limit okay that's more
complicated way of doing diesel in our
conversion actually overall it's almost
a nice way to think about digital RF
conversion yeah whatever
analog you're just accommodating the GM
variation essentially in the transistor
they're actually right way to think
about it is we're accommodating the AC
coupling from the gate to the drain
another effect yeah otherwise the gate
signal go right through so what you end
up having like you is talking with the
right direction table you get you get
feed through and say you end up as you
as you drop the power on your choke take
a transistor and then putting our our
signal you keep dropping part what
you'll find is
come down come down for now and then
they'll start to come back up because
the drive it's really gay starts to
become the dominant signal it goes
through a phase change two phases cancel
and then the gate becomes a dominant
phase and the power actually goes up
this is a gate to drain to source train
to gate capacitance in fact gate gate to
drain
yes that's what I meant to say okay
thanks yeah that's why product mode is
important really well documented in this
book yeah so our CTO unfortunately was
at a customer running a test today and
otherwise and he'll come back to view
the receiver talk in two years I just
threw him under the bus yeah you can
no show me for that Hey okay I'm fine
with that
he'll kill me you'll give me beer
afterwards it's okay um yes sir
are there any constraints on the
imposing Wiggins in this constraints on
the input signal I let me see if I can
answer your question we'll need uh
straight this is it's cute some of these
things because I could put in random
signals pride and queuing make something
work
so I want to show you this because this
is there's actually a huge amount of
value in here and this is why we'll be
talking to the FCC in a few weeks these
are all kinds of standard signals right
here's a five megahertz LT need Emily
here's a five megahertz LTE uplink this
is 16 384 clam and at WCDMA envelope
that's gmsk there's your 1.4 megahertz
LTE everything exactly following what
it's supposed to be doing and we got as
I said we got the five TNR signal we put
it in it works and I say this jokingly
but I'm serious you got 60 send it you
got 70 sent it
it's a software-defined radio we've
we've literally taken a signal and
splitted into two signals and
transmitted the same system okay so you
could
you can pretty much do just with
anything you can think of I mean there's
obviously if the think about how you
construct your signal to 14 reasonable
in some sense you have to take into
account the bandwidth of how much
bandwidth this thing can transmit and
those kind of things but it's logic a
within News Kent notionally at
reasonable constraints which are far
broader than than than anything like the
5g and our signal is it'll work
it's actually really people at keysight
when we tested and did that 16 3 the
fourth gram test over-the-air wasn't far
to maybe a meter and a half but it was
over-the-air it worked they were like
this is incredible so I mean yeah they
said they haven't seen anything uestion
the the critical piece that I want to
draw your attention to is if you look at
the LTE signal one of the challenges
that we're dealing with today is these
coattails down here and everybody has
them and that's one of the part offices
of the construction of the LTE signal
and you'll note that that's not in the
five GNR signal this is one of the
things that classic linear amplifiers
are having a lot of trouble with and we
have zero trouble with it and this is a
huge potential value not in places like
San Francisco or San Jose but in places
like the southeastern United States and
other places where you have secondary
providers who are kind of limping along
behind the big four in terms of how
where they can get spectrum and they
might only have four megahertz of
spectrum and because of the shoulders
that they have the keep outs for the LTE
they actually only get to put a two
megahertz signal in there well with what
we can do for them with these types of
software created envelopes is they can
now use three and a half megahertz out
of their four megahertz never mind
putting any more bit depths into what
they're doing simply expand the
shoulders out and you give them 80% more
frequency that's also a big deal that
comes into the spectrum efficiency side
of the house of what we can enable and
we do it at 50 percent efficiency so
those are when you start to think about
the kinds of things that a truly
software-defined radio at power
that's nice and wonderfully clean we'll
give you that's a big deal and those are
kinds of things that will be in a
position to realize relatively early
main sure we'd love to sign a contract
with Verizon and start doing all kinds
of things with Verizon but Verizon's you
know it's like signing a contract with
Apple when can we have a hundred million
units it's not a discussion worth having
right now right so crawl walk run I hope
that answers your question yeah kind of
curious if you have any uh patents
tonight no well so it's important up
door no has nothing to do with DARPA has
everything to do with early so Earl Earl
was I and I only threatened my
co-workers with extraction so it has a
lot to do with our CTO who was the CTO
at tro pian which was the company that
tried to do this in the 90s so we know
where all the dead bodies are buried so
we know everything that we have to
invent over we know which patents have
expired and we know what IP we need to
avoid so that's the reason that we have
an unblemished record at this point in
time
you